I'm so excited for you with this film in
Europe its massive Spain is loving you
you're getting a back best actor from
Ken now North America is fall in love
with you and this film what does it mean
as an actor to have that kind of impact
when you create your art it's beautiful
yeah it's beautiful
you know I mean the movies called pain
and glory yeah so difficult to explain
for example I just bought a theatre
three years ago in Malaga no we are
going to open now in November so I've
been working in this theatre for three
years with a team of people spending
time spending money spending a lot of
energy crossing every type of obstacle
and everything will be cure in the
opening night with an applause just
people applaud and everything goes when
all these pains becomes worried so we
are desired that crazy but it's true you
know it's true so that the movie has
been successful that we have a
opportunity to connect to people and to
share feelings and emotions with them
and that is very important for any
artist you know so and then then when
you feel rewarded if he comes in the
shape of an applause or if you come in
the shape of a little statue that they
give you is a beautiful thing yeah I'm
talking about connection you've had that
connection with Pedro in 1982 and he
said that you had the romantic face and
you should do movies having him part of
your life how has that been for you I
think he directed eight movies with you
yeah what's the impact has he had on you
I couldn't understand probably and you
know my relationship with especially
with cinema without the presence of a
paranormal or he's been for four decades
you know working with me and me with him
and we have done many things we are
friends for this 40 years almost and so
it has been a very interesting path that
we just went through Pedro is a very
loyal personality you get a very strong
one yeah but its own personality he
never betray himself they were offering
him everything money
everything from Hollywood I said no I
want to do my movies in the way that I
do them and he's long 21 of them and he
is very special you know it's very
difficult to find people like that do
you know you're so faithful to
themselves so he's a blessing it's a
blessing and he's very private so to be
able to do movie that reflects his life
were you surprised by anything that you
learned about him through this process
definitely because because in all of
these years that we have been friends
different shape got a very specific
University has boundaries and I never
tried to trespass those boundaries
because I am very respectful of whatever
people want to keep kind of like his
personal life yeah yeah something areas
of his personal life then you know we
never moved in that territory
we got an Universal of our own you know
for our relationship or for our
friendship so that yeah when I received
the script for the first time I was very
surprised to see that there were things
there that I didn't know especially in
things there has to do with the
relationship with his family especially
with his mother with actors with lovers
with life itself mm-hmm and you'd really
tap into what pain is and I think that's
a reflection what happened to you two
and a half years ago with your heart
attack and I have to tell you that two
and a half years ago my dad had a heart
attack as well and we found a tumor in
him so from my experience it changes you
we're gonna change my dad did it change
you as well absolutely yeah II did it
changes you because you are more
conscious of your vulnerability yeah and
and you see the only thing that actually
is certainty which is death everything
else in life is relative but that one
does perfect that comes when you see
that only the important things pop up
and then you can actually know you can
put in perspective everything else and
say okay this is what I really want to
do this is a real people that I love my
daughter my family my friends my
vocation my vocation no my profession my
location the thing
that I want to do as an actor I'm gonna
tell the story when I share experiences
with people that is for me the important
thing so yes it changes you
yeah it changes you for good I have been
saying these days that that experience
actually was one of the best things that
happen in my life and I know that many
people should get a little bit upset
about that is awful yeah yeah but I'm
talking about my own personal experience
and there are many different ways of
receiving a heart attack there are
people who can account you know and they
kind of tell the story because it comes
like a tsunami and that's it
but in my particular case he helped me
to understand myself better in
relationship with the life that I was
living how do you live life to the
fullest now well I do crazy things I
just found the perfect way to ruin
myself by buying a theater mala guises
you know I just understood that money is
just kind of an intellectual process
that we all are trapped in you know and
so but I fear it is something that you
can actually touch you can you can see
you can have young people play in there
and giving them what I didn't happen
when I went to start doing fears in the
70s in Malaga so I bought it in my
hometown and actually we attached now to
the theatre another theater that we're
building attached to a school where I
have six under students and so they
study in the morning academics and in
the afternoon civilians they do singing
dancing and acting so many of them that
came out of the school they are in the
West End in musical so they are in
Madrid or the interval show in Russia
have a ballerina in the world show in
Russia so you know and that is for me
beautiful thing to do you know there is
still in mind yeah we open now on the
14th of November and we are going to
open with a very classic American
musical the Seine a beautiful mess maker
of course we're gonna open with a chorus
line and co-directing and I am
performing Zack director/choreographer
can you tell Pedro to put you in
Penelope together in one scene one day
you guys are always separated and sees I
never see
together you have to make it happen you
know that we have trying both of us
I've been like I don't know I said I
have to find the story I have to find
the story and as I will find it you look
for it you know but it would be great
because I know Penelope oh my god ha
when she was you know a struggling
actress coming from is paying in New
York meet her in New York she was 19
years old at that time and then when
when she moved to Los Angeles and of
course I was still married with Melanie
and we opened our the daughter of our
home to her so in case you got any
problem and she has been always very
thankful for that but then she became
the star she became yeah we love you
thank you so much for coming in
you